so David what is the long term plan the
long term plan is the council's 10-year
plan for spending and income Oh over
that period that is something we do
every three years so it gets refreshed
every three years and it tells our
community how the council intends to
develop the district to learn in terms
of council activities over the next ten
years it's important to realize this is
a draft long-term plan so it's not
finalized and when we do have to consult
our community together and we welcome
that because the community is there it's
the long-term plan what are the big
issues facing our district in this
long-term plan all the number of big
issues we've got the continuing one of
developing our regeneration areas and
car poi and used to call Vincennes and a
number of projects attend up to that
including work heart around the Copper
River and developing sports fields and
passive areas in the in that area we've
got the food forest already underway
this which is a great community effort
and and so that's to me probably the
main thing yeah last few years have
really been massive earthquake
every second thing is the endorse
multi-use sports facility which is
proposed for our district based on
around Europe and it will provide
facilities for range of indoor sports
and there's been demand for that and
love evidence to suggest that we are
short of that kind of space thirdly I
think that's been very much in public
mind over the last few years is the
rubbish collection facilities we're
looking at often people of choice so
that people want three bins they can
have a little paper of course speak for
myself they'll be somewhere in the
middle I'll keep my black plastic bag
because that works for me and my wife
and but we wouldn't mind having the
green top then for garden waste so in
organics so that'll be that's there as
well
we've already consulted on that but
finally overarching there is the
question of rate rises and we we've
managed to keep our rate rises pretty
low and it's also signal to be pretty
low over the next 16 years and we we
were very aware that many household
rates are significantly expensive part
of the entire experience believe what
has it important for residents to have
they say because essentially it is the
long term plan because not the council's
actually one a flurry community
it's about the directions and a reset
for our community and of course as far
as rates are concerned its community
that's paying for how the residents make
a submission variety of ways you can do
it online now as you always seem to be
able to do these days through our
website the traditional way through a
written submission and you can also do
it by email and then having done that if
you wish to speak to the council and
hearing you you're welcome to do so so
and there some people always choose to
do that but also there will be a number
of events all throughout our district
where people come along and ask
questions and then find out a bit more
about our planes or where the things
that we're offering to the community
before we make a final scene in my
[Music]